tercis cela nous dit qu'on a la parole
et à monsieur alain marsaud merci
monsieur le président demain et après
demain monsieur le premier ministre
le sommet européen va aborder la
question notamment de l'accueil des
réfugiés la politique allemande est et
qui était je vous cite temporairement
justifié n'est plus tenable dans la
durée nos capacités d'accueil limitées
les tensions de ces dernières semaines
en allemagne mais aussi ailleurs en
europe nous oblige à dire les choses
clairement
l'europe ne peut plus accueillir tous
les migrants en provenance de syrie
d'irak ou de certains pays d'afrique
dire venez tous peut finir par détruire
les fondements de l'europe
c'est ce que vous avez déclaré monsieur
le premier ministre à munich lors d'une
conférence sur la sécurité
monsieur le premier ministre
permettez-moi en qualité de député de
l'opposition debout félicité pour ses
propos qui sont réalistes et qui
correspondent aux intérêts de la france
mais aussi au sentiment général de nos
compatriotes en qualité de député des
français établis hors de france et
vivent sur cette zone
je peux vous faire part aussi de leur
grande inquiétude même si monsieur
george clooney et john kerry soutiennent
madame merkel
j'ai envie de la répandre ou à terme ce
ya certains d'entre vous aussi et oui
vous ignorez vous n'ignorez pas monsieur
le premier ministre que selon nos
services de renseignement confiée par
les autorités européennes
mais complet elysées de votre
gouvernement
rené côte d'azur a écouté bien mes chers
collègues j'allais moins rigoler l'état
islamique s'apprête à mettre en place
une déferlante migratoire en provenance
des côtes libyennes
et ce en direction de l'europe dès les
premiers jours du printemps
est ce bien évidemment avec son cortège
de djihadistes
monsieur le premier ministre que sont
les mesures que vous comptez proposées
afin de parer à une telle offensive
notamment lors du sommet de demain je
vous en remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls se le député alain marsaud
l'europe du fait de la déstabilisation
du moyen orient d'abord
est soumise à une pression migratoire
sans précédent et face à cela il faut un
langage en tout cas de vérité de clarté
vis-à-vis des gouvernements européens
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens qui
légitimement s'inquiète et enfin dans
l'intérêt même il faut tenir ce langage
de vérité clarté dans l'intérêt même de
ceux qui fuit les persécutions etc ont
droit à notre protection avec la
nécessité de le faire à chaque fois la
différence en terme d'accueil entre ceux
qui ont droit à l'asile et ceux qui sont
des migrants économiques et c'est cette
confusion qui d'ailleurs peut mettre en
cause le régime même du droit d'asile
ce langage de vérité c'est que l'europe
n'est pas en capacité d'accueillir tous
les migrants et tous les réfugiés
elle ne le peut pas il suffit de
regarder la situation en allemagne j'y
reviendrai mais ce que connaît par
exemple un pays comme la suède qui avait
décidé d'accueillir sans limite et qui a
été amenée à rétablir le contrôle aux
frontières
l'urgence est donc de trouver une
réponse à ces flux migratoires et c'est
la position que défend la france depuis
plusieurs mois le ministre de
l'intérieur notamment a déjà eu
l'occasion de s'en expliquer ici même
c'est ce message que j'ai voulu passer à
munich tout en indiquant le respect
qu'inspire la décision des autorités
allemandes et en faisant part une
nouvelle fois de mon admiration pour
l'effort exceptionnel accompli par le
peuple allemand par les landers pour
l'accueil des réfugiés et des migrants
dès à présent au delà de ce qu'il faut
faire en syrie parce que il faut être
aussi cohérent quand on voit ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui les bombardements
russes sur des populations civiles du
côté d'alep les initiatives qui peut
être amenée à part un certain nombre de
pays de la région
est-ce que la situation en syrie va
s'arranger du fait de ces initiatives
non les réfugiés vont continuer à fumer
les zones de combat donc nous savons que
la solution est d'abord politique
diplomatique et militaire en syrie
comme en irak mais dès à présent il faut
mettre en oeuvre le plan d'action conclu
le 22 novembre entre l'union européenne
et la turquie une aide de trois
milliards d'euros est prévu pour aider
les réfugiés syriens qui se trouvent sur
le territoire turc la turquie doit
désormais mettre pleinement en oeuvre
ses engagements
il faut également assurer un contrôle
effectif aux frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne comme le prévoit
schengen et pour cela il faut adopter
dans les plus brefs délais les deux
propositions faites par la commission
c'est à dire d'abord créer un véritable
système de garde frontières européens et
ensuite mettre en place des contrôles
systématiques à l'entrée de l'espace
schengen enfin sur le territoire
européen
les décisions doivent être appliquées
mise en oeuvre des centres d'accueil et
relocalisation monsieur lucky et qu'est
ce qu'on attend
cette question vous la posez pas au
gouvernement français le gouvernement
français y compris dans les initiatives
avec le gouvernement allemand
par l'intermédiaire de bernard cazeneuve
et de thomas de maizière ne cesse de
demander la mise en oeuvre de ses
décisions parce que ces décisions n'ont
que trop tardé le conseil européen des
18 et 19 février sera l'occasion de
faire un point précis sur la mise en
oeuvre de tous les décisions qui ont été
prises ou annoncées
et je rappelle que la responsabilité
dans cette affaire est d'abord une
question de responsabilité collective et
comme elle le fait depuis le début de la
crise la france va évidemment continuer
à travailler de manière très étroite
avec l'allemagne mais nous devons le
faire avec une exigence de réalisme et
de vérité dans les échanges que nous
avons entre nous c'est essentiel pour
identifier ensemble les solutions
efficaces et sortir de cette crise qui
frappe l'europe toute entière qui risque
de faire un lien en plus entre le
terrorisme et la crise des migrants et
qui nous obligent
enfin et monsieur alain marsaud vous y
serez sensible à ce que l'europe et donc
la france défendent un véritable projet
pour la relation entre l'europe et
l'afrique parce que demain nous savons
que les migrations c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui viennent essentiellement
d'afrique
notamment d'afrique de l'ouest et du
sahel 80 millions d'habitants
aujourd'hui 150 millions demain des
francophones qui rompt normalement
logiquement vers la france et c'est ce
grand projet vers l'afrique que l'europe
et la france doivent porter merci